[Musik]
immer furchtbar ich bin zu sagen das
findet man nicht hegen können
[Musik]
lieber hendrik ich war eben doch sehr
sehr gerührt und auch weich geworden und
jetzt möchte ich mich ganz ganz herzlich
für dieses wunderschöne klavierspielen
bedanken
[Musik]
für mich ist es sehr schwer derzeit ja
sagt weimann fünf kinder unter einen hut
bekommen was wir eigentlich hätten
ostern gerne in bernau gefeiert bei ihr
zusammen mit ihr zusammen weil sie ist
anfeindungen schwer vaters vor zwei
jahren mit sturm ganz starke frau eine
ganz starke frauen ja alles im griff hat
sie vermisse mein mann verstorben ist
dann muss ich sie noch mehr
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch ganz truhe ostern auch
wenn die zu zweit jetzt leider daheim
seit und wir alle nicht dabei sein
können vor allem ich mit meinem baby
bauch und auch die eva mit ihrem
babybauch wir uns einfach ganz schnell
nach und nächstes jahr mit babys dann
umso schöner
sehr sehr schön auch hebammen haben es
in der korona zeit besonders schwer zara
shabani arbeitet in münchen bis zu 16
stunden am tag um all ihre frauen zu
versorgen
sarah shabani gehört in diesen corona
zeiten zu unseren helden des alltags und
bild möchte ihr jetzt das osterfest
verschönern und deswegen haben wir eine
kleine unschöne überraschung für sie
liebe sarah wir haben für dich ein auto
du bekommst ein renault zoe von uns ein
elektroauto damit du auch damit auch zu
deinem haus besuchen fahren kann
dankeschön
[Musik]